joining me here is my colleague from the
nfl media group who along with ian
rappaport has been killing it down at
the owners meeting and throughout this
entire non-plank season tom pelicero
joining us here from the breakers in
palm beach
what's up tom how are you
i hope that my voice is not drowned out
by the sounds of the waves crashing
against the rocks here on the lagoon
ridge it's uh fairly fairly picturesque
when i get a chance to come beyond the
building and talk to you here tom how
many times have you and i spoken i think
that's the first time you've ever used
the word lagoon with me
tom i'm not gonna lie
it's a first and i'm not gonna lie i had
to google and make sure what type of
body of water it was is in fact a lagoon
because there's an island beyond the
horizon and so this that separates this
lagoon from the atlantic you know that's
why your next level in terms of your
information is like you don't even want
to be inaccurate as to what to call the
water by this five-star resort that
we're all at right there where
everyone's at uh so let's get right into
it what what can you tell me about this
vote that went down today
behind the scenes
yeah rich this was always the most
likely outcome and we've talked about
this uh for a month or so on nfl network
it's
postseason only was the natural place to
begin in large part because the numbers
are far more skewed in terms of the
correlation between the coin toss winner
and the game winner than they are in the
regular season where it's 50 50. and
that's a function of course the fact
you've got better quarterbacks who are
in the playoffs you've got some offenses
that particularly in that bill's cheese
game last year appeared unstoppable so
it you know as much as they talk about
this is the equitable thing we want
everyone to have a fair chance there are
plenty of coaches and gm so i talked to
in recent days who think either it's not
worth making this change or go play
defense or you know no matter how many
times you go back and forth now the team
that you know the third possession that
can win and now that's going to be
unfair where does it end there's plenty
of coaches to feel that way but it's not
the coaches who cast the votes it is the
owners who cast the vote and when it
boils right down to it you are an
entertainment product as the nfl and the
consumers of that product roundly would
like to see the best players get an
opportunity in the biggest games and
that rule accomplishes this even though
as you mentioned there are going to be
unintended consequences and
we'll see how things play out
strategically in terms of how teams
approach this when the first time
they've seen it is in a defining moment
in their scene so other than i guess the
analytics departments who now get to dig
into this and figure out what the best
scenarios are and they can you know game
it all out and and run different
permutations of where the ball starts
and when you should get it and how you
should get it and what happens now i
think again most teams are going to want
to actually get the ball second in
overtime now and that might be the way
that the coin flip quote unquote decides
things what are you hearing uh around
the hotel there of how coaches and
general managers think this is going to
play out what the consequences of it
will be
best to their intentions
well one of the funny things that i
heard was that you had kind of this
analytics battle going on where one team
would present its data that its people
had put together and then other teams
would present different data based on
their analytical studies of the
situation so you absolutely had uh some
healthy back and forth here i had a long
conversation with a head coach of a team
the other day who said what's going to
happen because again the rule where you
know the other rules proposal where
would be if you scored a touchdown and
they got a two-point conversion in the
game ends on the first possession that
was really never going to gain traction
because it was viewed as too gimmicky
too far outside the fabric of the game
but this head coach said what's going to
happen is many if not all the teams that
end up with the first possession whether
they choose it or not if they score a
touchdown are going to go for two
because if you don't you see your
control over that situation in other
words you score a touchdown you kick the
extra point
now the other team can score touch don't
go for two and beat you now how many
people are going to do that it's
probably similar to the
mindset and the approach you would have
in regular season end of game type
situation but you mentioned the decision
on whether or not to take the ball uh
absolutely your part analytics a big you
know almost the entire thing of
analytics is you want as much
information as possible to guide your
decisions so i would anticipate that
many teams are going to be advised hey
if you win the coin toss defer in this
thing and then the team that gets the
ball first is going to be facing that
decision and i would not be surprised at
all if the majority of those teams go
for two so that they set the agenda and
say letting the other team have control
so then if if seeking information and
having it and war gaming it out and
presenting the head coaches with as much
of this data going into a possible new
ruled overtime
um and that's such a crucial aspect of
this
uh why
would owners not want this for the
regular season and pilot this thing
before
uh before the crucible of a winner go
home game in front of 50 million people
why not try it out where the first time
it happens is a a week three one o'clock
kickoff and and we could start to see
what unintended consequences are before
a
win or go home game what's up with that
it's a great question and the
explanation i've gotten on it is that
it's about the data points that the
owners looked at this and saw that it's
literally 50 50 uh in the regular season
in terms of winning the coin flip and uh
winning the game and then in the
postseason i believe it's ten and two
ten teams won the game after winning the
coin flip only two teams lost and so
that's what they wanted to address first
i would certainly think
that if this goes well and i don't even
know how you would define goes well
because obviously somebody's going to
walk away from all these situations
going boy that really burned us right
there if it goes well i would anticipate
that eventually it does get carried over
to
the regular season but the nfl has a
long history of when they make
these major types of changes they do
them incrementally uh they do them in
small portions uh you know to what
extent you know there was conversation
in the room about doing it within the
regular season that was the proposal but
again i go back to what we said a month
ago when i was told the thing that's
going to get the traction is the post
season only at least the start just
because the numbers are going to show
that we've got an issue here and a large
part of that because the quarterbacks
and those playoff games are so good tom
pelicero a few more minutes left uh with
my nfl media group colleague here taking
uh time out of uh being on television on
nfl network for calling in here so what
what is because there's the combine and
then there's this event i mean my god
chit chit-chat everywhere like literally
around every corner and every hallway
and every elevator and every bar and
every single restaurant it's insane so
um what's the talk about mostly outside
of this subject matter there at the
combine right there terms of the actual
yeah in terms of the actual agenda at
the owner's manual this is one of the
lightest i think we've ever seen oh i'm
not talking about that
i'm talking about what everyone else is
talking about what do you got for me
what do you think normally you've got
some yeah normally you've got some
ongoing things that are going to get
resolved but we're just we're not to the
point of you know any decisions on the
dolphins not to the point of any
decisions on desean watson but certainly
those two situations are going to
generate a ton of conversation i think
that you know all the the head coaches
and gm's that i you know have spoken to
this week i i think that the prevailing
question is just what's next like what
are you hearing is the next thing that's
going to happen because people bring up
wild situations right now i mean i had
one gm just tell me like it's the wild
west right now everybody thinks
everybody is available because we're
seeing trades unlike anything that we've
ever seen before and so teams are
getting calls on star players um there
are certainly teams that have been in
the mix and missed out for instance on
the wide receivers you would anticipate
are still going to be active here
leading up to and even after the draft
you've obviously got you know baker
mayfield situation which at this point
is dormant that may take a while jimmy
garoppolo um you know the headline
yesterday was john lynch saying they're
not releasing jimmy garoppolo which yeah
why would they release a guy with a
non-guaranteed salary who's shown when
he's healthy he's a pretty good
quarterback in the nfl just because they
haven't gotten the offer that they want
for him right now so that may take a
while especially after you know the
shoulder surgery that can be cleared
until close to the start of training
camp but i would say that's the number
one thing is just what's next and even
you know as much this year because we
still could get action here rich in the
coming weeks but you know next year
what's it what's it going to be one of
these star wide receivers going to want
um you know the way that you have right
now star players who are exacting their
leverage and their power over situations
more than they ever have before and
utilizing different means than they have
before employers greatest leverage was
for a long time not showing up
withholding your services not coming to
training camp well the 2020 cba made it
so punitive that we see a lot less of
that but players are figuring out other
ways to do it and making noise in the
offseason or you know things that might
seem silly like deleting instagram posts
it has an effect because we live in this
echo chamber and you live in an
environment right now where you know the
trades that
when you hear about them they almost
seem too dumb to check on they're not
too dumb to check on now like rapport
and i talk about that all the time like
you check on everything you can hear the
stupidest thing ever but you have to
make a call because i mean who would
think going into this off scene yeah
tyra kills going to be traded to miami
and devonte adams is going to be treated
to the raiders in the one-week span and
yeah we'll deal russell wilson and matt
ryan you know nothing big nothing major
we've never seen anything like this
before and so
that's going to have a ripple effect and
you know as much as the rams went all
all in last year and won the super bowl
and everybody wants to point to that
you've got how many seven eight nine
teams that made a massive trade in this
offseason it's not gonna work out for
everybody and so teams are gonna be
analyzing how these situations play out
and certainly there are plenty of
players and agents uh particularly at
the wide receiver position to see where
the numbers are going uh and can't wait
to have their opportunity to try to pull
off the same thing in the in the
category of uh it's no longer too dumb
to check on brady being traded to the
dolphins is did that even get a phone
call for you to check on that that that
crazy rumor that's been everywhere
trending on twitter all of that
tom we check on it we check on
everything rich we we check on
everything i mean again mike mcdaniel
had to answer it uh called fake news it
would it would seem implausible at this
point uh in part because tom brady from
even before he made the announcement on
his own retirement was uh lobbying some
of his teammates to come back and
calling people within the league he's a
a plus recruiter and he was doing that
to tampa it would seem surprising
at this stage to think suddenly now he's
gonna go out the back door uh and end up
in miami i would also say at some point
you would certainly anticipate that they
have to address tom brady's contract
because he's got i want to say it's a
placeholder year for about 10.5 million
that he's on this year that was never
intended to be played on the idea was
keep adding a year to his contract you
know give him a lump sum this year like
they did last year when he made 40 plus
million i would certainly think that's
what's next for tom brady but rich you
do check on everything i bet and so um
justin if i do have two more minutes
with you i just want to bite on one of
the things you just said tom
um is that uh you called tom pelosa here
on the rich history you called the baker
mayfield situation dormant now
why would it be dormant lack of interest
lack of interest
is it a money thing that browns won't
eat his salary there there's there's
nothing on the table they consider
worthy of baker mayfield he wants to go
some place that's not
willing to take him why would this be
dormant right now
you do 18.8 million dollars fully
guaranteed
at a time that the browns are not simply
going to give him away and they don't
intend to release relation and they're
just aren't very many starting jobs
uh available so if he's going to be
traded to let's say hypothetically a
tampa which of course they want a young
guy to groom they got kyle trash there
too but you're thinking ahead and you
want the next guy behind tom brady
you're not going to take on baker
mayfield who right now would be making
double what you're starting quarterback
the greatest who's ever played tom brady
is making so you would need cleveland to
eat a chunk of that money now i can tell
you
cleveland was initially having trade
calls they did not want to eat money and
the price was pretty high it's pretty
similar to what all these quarterbacks
is they want a second round pick uh and
something else for baker mayfield at
this stage it is difficult to
believe that he's going to get that i
think that there are i know that there
are teams who did not have baker
mayfield you know with a first round
grade coming out in the draft several
years ago so that's a factor to your
prior evaluations and then what happened
when he played for last year i don't
think that there are 32 better
quarterbacks than baker mayfield in the
nfl if you get back to the 2020 baker
mayfield but again the money and the
drastic compensation and situation all
have to line up for baker mayfield i do
anticipate to be wearing a different
jersey uh certainly by week one and most
likely by the start of training camp but
for the browns the way that they look at
things there's really not a big rush on
him his contract's already fully
guaranteed that's a change from the the
prior cba that would have been able to
get out of it for a certain league here
in the old uh the old like a bargaining
agreement now you're locked into that
money
and ultimately you may have to eat some
of it to move on from so they can stand
past see what else might happen what
crazy thing is behind door number two
that i mean nobody would have thought
two weeks ago that matt ryan would end
up with the colts after a failed push by
the falcons that's sean watson i mean
there's just there's dominoes all over
the place right now it's hard to predict
where they're gonna fall yeah and what's
the escrow check that the haslams are
going to have to scratch for desean
watson well how much is that check going
to be
it's 184 million after the 46 million
they pay them this year they get a
credit for about 15 million of that but
that's uh that's a big reason that
students don't want to do this the
owners aren't you know they're not rich
guys for no reason having 180 million
dollars sitting there in a bank rather
than uh being able to you know play in
the market and and make money off it is
not ideal for anybody is absolutely
owners and other you know gm's were
upset about um you know the contract and
the way that it was structured in the
amount of fully guaranteed money not
only because of the situation with the
sean watson but you know as one league
executive or team executive early
respect for it like they just changed
the entire landscape of economics in the
nfl and now every agent every player is
going to want a similar type of deal
we'll see who's willing to go there um
it's just it
changed how people are going to look at
this moving forward all right well enjoy
the lagoon the rest of the day and uh
the rest of the uh
your stay there in uh in palm beach
thanks for the time tom excellent as
always thank you anytime rich thank you
you got it that's tom pelicero hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here